the jurgen experience what are you
thinking about pulling the trigger on
what am i adding or taking away what are
you adding
i love this kid's thing i mean if you if
you know that's why i asked you about
stand-up comedy versus the podcast or
anything you do
if you put a gun to my head or a knife
like you did earlier when you tested me
[Laughter]
i um i i like the kids the kids are like
wet clay in the sense that um
you really feel like you make an impact
i mean i feel like i make an impact i've
been getting
we didn't talk about this i've been
getting some 21 or 22 year olds from
very very wealthy families
that are saying hey joe they know me
through somebody whatever
um my kids are a little they need some
help
i want to put them on the farm with you
they're hard to fix
by the time they're 21-22 they're hard
to fix these these little kids
um i make a big impact i mean the
letters i got
are tear jerkers after after the after
the
text i saw them writing the parents
about how terrible i was
yeah and then seeing 14 days later like
the impact
yeah i want i want more yeah
you know no i think you're dead right
about that
if you can give a kid a like a
transformational experience when they're
when they're young something that really
sticks with them that's the rest of
their life
right yep and and uh the other thing i
like about it is they can't really quit
right you know if the parent gets
involved then it's all [ __ ] up but if
the parent stays out of it
we're doing a mate i got i didn't i'm
doing another one right now while i'm
sitting here i got another i got another
20 kids there right now
and uh they're there in vermont right
now who's running he's cracking the whip
andy the olympian the mountain warfare
guy eric ashley
and um they're kicking these kids asses
and they're running this every two weeks
with new
new groups i mean it's selfish for me
because i want my i want my kids to keep
just re-enlisting right
right and so i need more kids for them
and so i just hit up another group and
some of the old kids came so this is
their second tour we'll call it
yeah which is great one of them is an 11
year old girl that's just
badass stoic and um
and one of the older boys i found out
last night when i got to california
is hitting his dad up and saying you got
to get me out of here you got to lie to
joe
and tell him we have a family vacation
get me the [ __ ] out of here and the dog
is oldest 15 and and the dad hit me up
and and i said listen next time he talks
to you
tell him we have an 11 year old girl by
his side
that is finishing this thing are you
kidding me so um
you can't blame them because they've
never tested themselves they've never
done hard things
right but i love it how are you
structuring this do you sit out in
advance and decide what they're going to
do
like every day so andy andy the the
olympic wrestler
um when he 2008 olympian um
didn't meddle went to russia and he
spent a couple of years in russia to
learn their system why did the russians
get all these gold medals in wrestling
and they climb mountains and they climb
ropes and they just [ __ ] work hard
and not that american wrestlers don't um
and so we took
a bunch of that russian system we took a
bunch of the mountain warfare stuff and
then we just added the spartan sprinkles
in there and the stuff my mom
the sport sprinkles wrinkles and so you
know they're waking up early
they're hiking the mountain uh they're
doing miserable [ __ ]
carrying rocks always purposeful so
we're building uh
we're building stuff out of the rocks
they'll be there for the test of time
and so they have they can come back and
see the efforts
of their work and cold water is always
involved because as you said with the
shower cold water sucks
um they drink only water as well they
drink only water all the doritos all
that stuff is gone
it's only three meals a day it's healthy
food um
probably keeping them a little bit
hungry um because
you know a lion is most handsome when
it's hungry um not
true yeah i mean it wants food i've
never heard that the most handsome ones
are hungry i mean right it's ready to
attack yeah and so um
so yeah in bed early um we are issuing
phones for 30 minutes they get to text
or call their parents or whatever
we're doing two days on uh this
particular camp is much more wrestling
focused
so two days on uh and then one day to do
a big hike so they did a giant hike
today
so they do wrestling yeah this this
even the first camp i didn't say to you
we had a fight club every day
so they were some of them were wrestlers
some weren't there were girls in there
never done it before
and we created like a brad pitt fight
club down the basement with andy
and uh it was awesome the kids [ __ ]
loved that part of the camp every day
they loved it
so they beat each other up and beat a
truck it was wrestling so it was smooth
he set the rules it was like hey i just
want you to get a high single leg this
is what it is right so
there were games like that oh okay they
loved it they'd pound the mat they'd be
screaming for an opponent
it was it's almost instinctual or
something it was unbelievable
it's great that you keep them from their
phones for that long too
yeah it was it was um yeah it was great
so yeah so that's great
[Applause]